foreign
[Applause]
sending many people in the city of
Savari from their sleep into a panic
these explosions are part of what mali's
military say was a sophisticated attack
on the main airport in the region of
mukti
a suicide Car Bomb was used in the
assault but Charles also landed on
people's homes in the city center people
here tried to pull out survivors from
under the rubble the man filming on his
cell phone says 20 people from one
family were trapped here all are dead
now
after several hours of heavy fighting
U.N peacekeeping soldiers from Senegal
repelled the attackers trying to capture
the airport shells landed on a camp
housing Russian fighters from the Wagner
group no one has claimed responsibility
for the attack but it has the Hallmarks
of armed groups linked to isil that are
active in the region and to the al-Qaeda
affiliate Jamal Islam Al Muslim also
known as jenim everything is pointing
toward the genome group because this is
the type of a attack they would do and
they have been clear over the past few
months that they will not tolerate the
presence of Russians among the malians
official
narrative around the Russian presidents
in Mali has so far been that they are
bringing training but more and more
reports are coming out that is saying
and that the Russian Fighters are
actually at the Battlefront the military
says its troops are combing the city
looking for enemy patents but some
people are taking Justice into their own
hands this man is a suspected attacker
and appears to have his hands and feet
tied they ask him where are you fleeing
where are the others
this was supposed to be a day for people
to celebrate the Muslim festivities of
Eid instead it's a day of Bloodshed the
governor of Savari says blood donations
are needed urgently hospitals are
overwhelmed by casualties and the people
of Savari are trying to make sense of
the violence and continuing to look for
survivors under the rubble
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera